as chair of the housewares and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
this public bond is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a revenue work session please
note there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen
temporarily to this meeting however in
accordance with the emergency order i am
confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries who listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting by zoom
platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available on
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notices meeting complies with the
house schools rsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email hcs
at lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
joined and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
christopher shea and jen
four please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
stacked a meeting by taking a roll call
of attendance and each member states
that presidents please also state
whether there is anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
representative bernstein we want to take
the role thank you mr chair and good
morning to you
good morning everyone it's tuesday june
the 8th 2021
it's 9 03 a.m we'll begin roll call with
representative patrick abrami
yeah yes i'm here in my home in stratham
alone
representative mary griffin
representative russ ober here in hudson
with the six cats who are very happy for
the air conditioning
i would imagine so representative fred
doucette
your clerk is alan bursty and i'm in my
home office by myself in nottingham new
hampshire
representative robert elliott here in
salem new hampshire
and my wife is uh recuperating in the
bedroom
it's good that she's home send her our
good wishes
representative john genigean yes i'm
here in my home in salem and my wife is
in the house
representative herschel nunes good
morning i'm home alone in very warm
pelham new hampshire
representative but you are one cool cat
so you will fare just what
representative walter spillsbury good
morning home alone in charlestown
good morning representative paul tudor
um home alone in northwood
representative susan
malone in lebanon representative richard
ames
i'm here in jeffrey in my home office
alone
representative dennis malui i'm here
alone in greenland
my favorite part of roco the honorable
representative thomas c
schamberg thank you uh mr clerk
bursting i'm here in hot and humid
wilmette my wife and i are in our
offices and we have four
uh gentlemen downstairs that are putting
in wood in the living room
kitchen dining room and the hallway well
it's good to see you do us a favor and
just tip your cat to us
there you go
home alone in randolph representative
gomarlo
i'm home alone i hope if that snake
shows up you'll know it
um
[Laughter]
representative tom laughman
representative amanda gorg good morning
i am present and alone
good morning representative mary hacken
phillips
representative james murphy good morning
i'm home alone in hanover
chairman representative norman major
right now i'm alone in my home in plasto
my wife should be coming home soon
uh representative bernstein did we get a
response from
uh i have fred marcus absent
i i am present mr clark home alone in
salem
uh thank you mr chair and and thank you
representative
mr chair there are 18 members present
six are not here
i've scheduled two meetings this week
one today and one tomorrow
the only reason i schedule a meeting
tomorrow
is in case we needed it we didn't finish
our work today
because if we didn't finish our work
today and i hadn't scheduled then
we couldn't hold a meeting tomorrow so
tomorrow's meeting is dependent upon
where
where we stand today and if we do meet
tomorrow
because of timing schedules we would
meet at ten o'clock
i've i've had some discussions with
senator ryder
and with crochet
and i got a feeling that if we
push it maybe beyond 12 or so we might
be able to not meet tomorrow but let's
there's a few things i want to mention
and so i've got a senate message and
and that house bill 15 was to deal with
the car rental
make sure that all car rentals pay the
rooms and meals tax it would be
effective 60 days after passage
so if um let's say it passed and the
governor signed it
july 1st then
the senate at the request of the gra
changed it to october 1st just another
30 days
does anybody on this committee have a
problem with that
it's not is everybody on the committee
an agreement to concur
we don't take a vote just put your hand
up if they're not
not or yes if you don't want to concur
so i'm going to re represent
over but no
i don't see any hands so i'll let the
clerk know that we will be concurring
now this past week
which would put the landfill bill
house bill 177 on 103 and 103 was the
disaster related
emergency bill which allowed
these utilities in an emergency to come
in and start restoration
without all the required
paperwork that would normally go with
that
i talked to senator greiter and
senator ryder the senate position is
they who would want to take it out
uh committee or conference so
i'm sorry could you repeat that senator
uh geider feeling is at the committee of
conference
the senate would want to remove the
177 from 103 because they
this the senate will probably send us a
message
uh one concurring forming a committee of
conference
on that so they will form
i'm asking because i'm the prime sponsor
of
hb 177. and i haven't been through this
with a bill of mine so i need to
understand
what you're saying so it will go to a
committee of conference
if they concur and form a committee
conference they will
if they do not concur dials
and so you're telling us those die so
what are you telling us that you think
is going to
uh senator god has said that it goes to
committee conference
that the senate will
want to remove it since they as a senate
senate bill 103 is a
very important bill for the state and
they know that
that's why they put it onto this bill
i think we've got to concur i mean we've
got to uh i think we got to go to the
committee at conference
we have to go to committee conference
some of us on
obviously those of us who were on
winning side of the
amendment would want to be represented
on that committee of conference
thank you all right so
uh then the position of the committee
and let's see if we
agree with this is to
non-curb concur and form a committee
a conference or that they would have to
do that
that's what that's that's going to be
their message to us and i guess
we're saying yes we'll accept the
committee a conference our position
right now
that was settled on the floor with a
all right and then the third one
i talked to senator geider relative to
senate bill 101
was changed from 75 000 to 92 000 to
account for
foster living and then the addition
of having a cost of living factor in
there going
forward he he has talked to
the prime sponsor that bill and she does
if not then we'll go into the revenue
press say
good morning reps of major i'm here okay
good
now of course we'll go over the senate
ways and means revenues that are in
their past house bill 1 and hospital 2.
we must remember when we did our revenue
estimates
it was in march 18th we didn't have
the full revenues of march
all the four revenues of april which are
the two heavy revenue
producing months so the senate had an
so
um so we'll go over that
i i think that there's not that
well let's go over and take them one at
a time go ahead
chris it's yours to explain the senate
revenue estimates relative to what we
did
okay represent major thank you um i on
friday
or maybe it was thursday i sent an email
to the full committee with two attached
documents
um one of them was a pdf file dated may
2021 and it said final on it and i'm
going to pull that up in the share
so the first the first page
after the date page let's blow it up a
little bit
are the dra tax estimate ranges that
they provided for the business tax meals
and rooms tobacco
real estate transfer utility property
all the same taxes that they did with
your committee
back in um march with different numbers
because there's
a different time period exactly so
they're updated to reflect
um what occurred through april
and if you were to look back at what you
had back in march and what you see here
the numbers are going to be
slightly different in some instances and
and largely different in others
particularly with the business taxes
but again they the process was similar
to what you went through where dra
provides a
a high and a low and then a percent
growth to apply to the low and a percent
growth to
apply to the high to provide a range for
the committee to consider when they're
so what we have here is is your current
law estimates for your
various revenue sources and you had the
plan for fiscal year 21 and then the
house ways in means for 21 22
23 followed by the senate weighs in
means 21
22 23 and then the difference between
your estimates
in all those estimates this is where the
anomaly removed from 21.
yeah so you'll notice there's an
asterisk on the fiscal year 21
that indicates that that 30.8 million
dollars
was removed from each of the business
taxes excuse me each of the tax sources
described below
so for instance the business taxes had
18.2 million dollars removed from that
in the base number um meals in rooms had
1.6 million
adjusted downward so yes
these numbers um are net of the the
so so the largest difference um is in
your business taxes
um you can see the senate ways and means
for fiscal year 21
is 126 million dollars higher than what
the house projected
or estimated 150 million higher than
in 22 and then 159 million dollars
higher
in 23. and again that's um
a result of of the numbers that came in
in april
um and then some assumptions that the
committee made um
in terms of growth going into 20 22 and
23.
um represent brahmin you have your hand
up all right representative
let me show you are we going to discuss
after you get done explaining the
columns are you going to go through all
of them or
are we going to discuss each one as we
go along we we can do it however is
easiest for the committee
i think for completeness we should take
one at a time both of the business taxes
and the meals and loans and
tobacco taxes right so i'll have a
question as soon as you're done
explaining the columns uh chris no i i
think you can you can ask representable
that's pretty much the columns and
and it's you know it's fairly simplistic
um presentation
um okay no i think we've seen this
this before so uh in terms of the
format uh so as of the end of
uh may the revenues were 848.1 then you
have to subtract
18.3 so that puts us at 829.8 million
dollars
that's in the door and obviously we
we had estimated uh 837 so that's
to get to the senate's number
you have to add 133.4
million dollars for june yep question i
have is
what was planned for june
somebody have that handy i couldn't find
my document
i've got it it's on
129. so they're being very conservative
okay so so and uh
i guess the all i'm suggesting is that
the question is does anybody feel that
we're not going to hit the 129.3
or we think we're going to hit the 133.4
uh you know that's you know uh three
four million dollar four million dollars
more
uh in june so that's to me that's how we
resolve this first column because
then everything else is driven off of
that for the for the
out years so uh what did you say 129
point 129.3
and i estimated out from that
two different ways and came
in considerably above the senate
number but i'm wondering if um the dra
is worried we may have refunds or that
there are other signs that things might
might
be slowing down in june that we should
be afraid
i've asked the dra to be with us
jen would you make sure they're to bring
amendments
uh melissa is on the call i saw her name
on the screen and and i don't mind if
she
would like to jump in um at any point
but
i think the dra is
doing the best that they can and making
the estimates based on the the
wildly inconsistent nature that we've
seen revenues
occur in the last three four months
i don't think anybody anticipated to see
revenues especially in the business
taxes to be where they are
right now um but
i'll defer if melissa would like to make
a comment um
and i don't mean to put you on the spot
melissa i apologize no
no worries uh melissa rollins senior
financial analyst for department of
revenue
um good questions i do want to note that
uh when the senate did theirs may their
estimates may hadn't fully been
um completed yet and may did come in
higher than anticipated
uh part of that i believe was due to the
um federal extended due date i don't
think we anticipated as many taxpayers
were going to take
advantage of that as you know new
hampshire did not extend their due date
so may came in 14.8 million
higher than our low end in 10.9 million
higher than our high end so there is a
little bit of a discrepancy there
because it did come in higher than
anticipated
and again senate didn't have made
chair i'm just trying to be i guess we
got to decide on what
methodology we want to use to come up
again if we use if we use the
[Music]
129.3 million
which is the plan
and we add it to the 829.8
yeah nine point three twenty nine point
three
and as of may we're at
after we take out the anomalous revenue
that's 829.8
and the senate's at nine
uh was the senate at 9 63.2
did i do that right
right but susan is saying that
she she came up with you came up higher
on well the slightly lower number that i
came up with
was taking the average excluding 2020
of on the last five years
of how much june is relative to the
entire year
and that one produced 900 taking out the
18.3 whatever it is
uh 990.1
which is considerably higher but on
paying early or whether there are going
to be more refunds
on so i was just wondering if the dra
was
being cautious or whether they were
thinking in terms of
of the month before which is what they
did in
in the may 26 document
they started from april
but if we did uh make this number higher
i think that we should
anticipate less growth
let me just do one thing uh dra's dras
range
was uh 9 9 47.5
and the low high is 964.9
divided by 2. so their midpoint
was 956.2
and then doing doing what i did taking
actual plus plan
gave us 959.1
so i i i want to just to get just to
break the uh break the
ice here let's just to say
okay i'll put that on the table as a
potential
number 969.1 right
and then the basis is current actual
actual room a
plus plan 959.1
and that is that is slightly above
like uh three million above
let's call it three million above the
melissa on your estimates a lot
low and high that has removed the
anomaly
i'm not wedded to this i'm just saying
uh represents spellsbury yes
thank you mr chairman um i guess i'm
looking for some help understanding this
as a freshman going through it the first
time but
if we accept uh
representative abrami's methodology
had 959.1 uh what we're doing is we're
we're making our best guess of what
actually is received
without regard to whether us a
significant
portion may be then subject to to refund
so given the amount of uncertainty
both on the question we had discussed a
couple of months ago regarding the
credit carry forward overhang as well as
the doubt about how much is attributable
to estimates that assumed
my concern is how do we go about making
our forward projections for fy 22 and 23
and the suggestion was made a moment ago
maybe we need to adjust the growth rates
but it seems to me the better
methodology
would be to keep the same growth rates
unless there's an economic reason to to
change them
but to make a downward adjustment in the
base
so that fy21
at 959 is adjusted downward
to correct for what we think is the
aberrational
uh excess that may have to be refunded i
don't know how to guess at that figure
but methodologically i think it makes
more sense to adjust
the fy21 base down
and then apply the same growth rates for
fy 22 and 23 that we previously assumed
oh mr chair can i react to that please
represent brian
i'd love to do that too but i think we
have to come in with a real number
for the base because that that number is
real when it comes to finance
they they use that number because
they're going to spend that number
in future years uh the overage based on
that number
uh uh so i i i can remember we're
projecting what it really is going to be
uh i think we have to do our adjusting
and out years
as i you understand that you follow that
logic
we can't maybe that we can see what we
can do is
look this is what we think the revenue
is really look we're only debating right
now
one month we know you know what the
money's
what money has come in already through
the first 11 months
we know it's going to be much higher
than plan uh
so we can't really adjust that down when
we show it now when we
when we do our math going forward we can
on the side
say okay this was an unusual
unusual base here high
because of uh the the ppp all that all
that stuff
and on the side we can reduce it and
then do our percentages going forward
but i think we have to show i think we
have to show 2001 as to what it really
is going to be
so i think we may be saying the same
thing representative abrami
i agree that fy 21 has to show what we
think we're actually going to collect so
whether that's 959 or 963
that's the figure we have to show for fy
21. i'm just saying that
in calculating 22 and 23
uh changing the growth rate implies that
we think the economy is doing something
different whereas changing the base
from which the uh
the growth rate is applied is
methodologically more sound how much of
an adjustment
to make to the base i don't know so i'm
only talking about how we go about
projecting
22 and 23. okay why don't we concentrate
on the base for 21. we found out
what the mythology was for getting to
the 959.2
of 0.1 and that's to
take the revenue that has come in the
door
up to date add the plan for
june and that gives you the 959.2.1
but now who who here
is say that the
revenue is going to come in as planned
or under
i don't think so the revenue is going to
come in
higher because all the other months have
come in higher
and then the reason and the reasons that
they come in higher
is a combination of a lot it's
the various stimulus things is probably
contributed to a lot and that's going to
continue
in june so the number that you came up
with 959.2
needs to be adjusted
and i feel upward
by an amount which
nobody really knows it
the representatives thank you um
am i on yeah um
i should preface what i say by noting
that i was off
the internet for about 15 minutes it
failed so
i missed some of the preambles to this
but
i certainly support adjusting the number
to the reality that we see now for
fiscal year 21 to get the best number we
can in terms of actual revenues that
will be collected
um and i
so that's that's that then i would also
say that i think it's pretty important
to
uh have an asterisk a footnote uh
some way of differentiating between that
which we
feel is what we might call base
that can be projected forward and uh
that which
is in some way different and
we've got a precedent for this a couple
years ago we had
a huge anonymous amount of money pouring
in
to the state through uh probably through
foreign dividends that were taxable in
new hampshire as a result of the federal
tax reform law bringing causing
repatriation of money by
mega corporations and uh so we had
we did the same thing at fy 21 we had
we had the total but we had we had sort
of the base
number that we thought was the base
number and
then we split out the anomalous number
um
and that that aspect of our revenue
collection for that year was mentioned
in our
in the cafe actually um so
um here we are in a
very different but similar conceptually
at least
situation and we've
uh we've got uh the uh
difficult uh we've perhaps a more
difficult
separation issue i think it's more
difficult than
back in fy19 um
because it's so difficult to calculate
there's the uh what uh representative
spillsby mentioned the
uh the sp3 uh
ppp issue um and
potential for refunds related to that
there's um in a very large sense there's
this
uh incredible stimulus economic stimulus
hit new hampshire in a favorable way
billions billions of federal dollars
flowing into new hampshire enabling
people to buy things that they weren't
wouldn't have bought before enabling
businesses to carry on where they would
have failed
and so forth we all know that this is
true
and when you've got that much money
that's
out of the norm flowing in you're going
to get
you're going to see it in tax revenues
and i believe that's what's happening
uh with our business revenues i can't
prove anything but
i believe there is a phenomenon here and
at the very least we should note it
and it should lead to caution
as we make projections going forward
and as our successors two years from now
try to
make make projections off of whatever
thank you representative some good some
good thoughts
um representative bromley i
again i'm fine with uh all of what's
been said uh
the other thing we should point out is
that the senate agrees with us
that in in after after they
projected their revenues
they they went along with the
the concept of of the surplus statement
and they took the dras number that they
gave the dra gave us
so in the surplus statement they're
reducing 22 business taxes by
25.4 million and in 23 they're basically
they're reducing
business taxes by 44 million 44 million
so we just got to keep that in mind that
that
after we get done projecting 22 and 23
understand that on the surplus statement
we're gonna we're gonna be subtracting
some of that revenue the 25.4 and the 44
point
uh for the fact that
uh payments there's going to be refunds
basically or less quarterly payments
going on in those two years because of
people already paying the tax but i also
appreciate the fact that
and i agree with with representative
spillsberry and representative ames
that there's something here uh that
we really should be reducing the base it
does seem like a false space to me as
well
um to then then move forward
with our projections based on what we
think the
real economy is going to be uh so
and i think representative major is
basically
i think you're saying the same thing
that uh
that while you're saying that the base
actually should be more than the plan
because of all this other stimulus i
mean the pp app alone was 3.7
billion yeah so
uh so i you know i'm willing to
increase my methodology by something
uh i don't know what the something is uh
to say that the base is probably going
to be greater than the
the actual may minus 18.3
by the way two documents i was using the
i've been using 18.3 for the uh based on
the
uh revenue focus because the actual
number is
eighteen point two seven two
[Music]
eighteen million two hundred seventy two
thousand six hundred twenty three
so to me i round up that's eighteen
point three uh but on this sheet it's
saying eighteen point two for business
tax
so whatever so it's a point one
either way so so i'm saying yeah
if we if we wanna the starting point is
is my age 59.1
now the question on the table is do we
want to increase that
or what representative major said about
all the extra revenue and then we then
we go back to uh
discussion on 22 and 23. okay
let me throw in a starting point for
that
take the 959.2
and the revenues to date on business
taxes
i've been up about 30
so let's say that the uh and that's on
the average for the whole
11 months so let's say that june is
going to come up
come up higher than was planned by
20 but
about 25 million dollars
yeah 25 million to the 959
at 984.
984 put you in uh
probably around a three percent increase
at all
the senate by the way the senate went
through
but they didn't have the advantage of
having the may
finals and so
that could have been another 25 million
dollars
so um i
i would stick i i would
have the committee steered towards
something that
around 20 more for
seeing that for the whole year
the average was 30 percent this would be
a conservative if you want to go to 30
let's hear from somebody else uh
representative
jennings thank you mr chairman
um i was just wondering and maybe this
data is already available
but i mean obviously one of the big
concerns here is
how the base figure may drop based on
ppp loan
um or based on refunds from
from non-taxable ppp loans um
is it possible if you're not already
doing it to track monthly
how much dra is sending back to
businesses
or to taxpayer well businesses based on
the ppp
loans because that would help us decide
how much we might have to lower whatever
base we come up with
we won't start seeing those numbers of
any substantial until
october or later
okay and because most of the
uh ppp loans haven't been approved
and then that's why in april
we got this log of money because they
couldn't
take the advantage of that they had to
pay it
knowing that they get it back as a
refund and it isn't just
the ppp loans that we're talking about
here
it's the others the main street and all
the others the stimulus packages that
have added to the revenue that's coming
in
those things are going going to be going
away
so what representative spillsbury he
said and others
and what we need to take
all of that into consideration as we go
out to 22 and 23.
but let's continue on fixing the base
for 21. uh reps of major can i just make
a comment or
response to representatives yeah sorry
not going to say it right sorry
representative um
um so dra at the end of the month does
send out a series of reports and one of
those reports is the refund analysis
so you can see on a monthly basis on
what's happening with refunds that are
being requested and paid out
in addition there's a report that goes
to fiscal committee on a quarterly basis
that dra does
on the refunds so so there is there is a
material out there
um available to you to look at what's
going on
but to the point represent major made
some of the
uh ppp you will probably won't see any
of that until sometime into the fall or
okay
thank you well uh we're
trying to deal with that with the future
stuff which is
quite different at this point and
i'm really going to want to get in on
that one but when we're looking at
what's coming in the door in
june to add on to this on
i'm willing to go along with the senate
number if we have to
but on if you
uh take the normal performance of june
relatives the rest of the year
we come up to 990
on half of that would be
an increase of 45 on
the 20 increase in june over
plan of 25 is something also i would be
willing to accept at this point but
those
that that is the range in there once
we've
included what may actually brought in
part of which we know was supposed to be
in april
okay does somebody else have a number
for fy21
that includes all of june revenue
norm you you susan's number's 990. your
number turns out if it at 20
is 985.1
so uh both tracking much higher than
the the senate 963.2
um
uh i just wanted to clarify what those
were yeah sorry i was
was my arithmetic was off you're right
representative major and i are very
close
so so that right we're saying that
uh that okay
you got me off my plan number there's
good arguments why it would probably be
above plan
and uh so again at the 20
above plan norm for for june that's is
it's uh that's uh
that's 25.86 million
so when you add it to the the
to the base that comes out to 9.85
the normal plan it comes out to 985.1
so i guess that's what's on the table
now all right does anybody else have
another number
other than that for 21.
then my suggestion is that we take
the difference between nine ninety nine
ninety nine
eighty five and come in with nine
eighty eight
of devon i know it's early on
and it's hard well his numbers he
compares to uh
compares to last year but last year was
really anomalous
at the beginning of the year uh
but how are revenues is david on
devon on how how the revenues look for
the first
representative rami i can answer that if
you'd like
um we do have a comparison just of to
last year and you are correct last
year's anomalies but
um business taxes is coming in pretty
good so far this year
um every just about every day has
exceeded
last year at this point for business
taxes
so yeah if we can have a 20 to 25
add-on that sounds reasonable for
guesstimate based upon the information
we know at this point in time
yeah i think it's a little bit higher
than what we'd had so if we plug in
what came in for may remove our
estimates and plug in what we came from
may and then keep our june
our june methodology the same we get a
new range of 960 2.3
to 975.8 uh
hold on one second you get a 962
0.3 to 9
75.8 and again that's replacing our may
estimate with may actual
and keeping our june methodology the
same
and and what we've done is exceeded that
by
12 12 million dollars okay
which is one and a half one third
we're down close all right
uh the basis of what
melissa said
the
million should that be changed
they would exceed the ra's high of 975.8
money in the doors as of yesterday
is that correct melissa
that's based on the end of may
so what did you take for growth
over plan for june
sure so um the way we had originally
modeled was based on historic
performance of may and june
but now that we have may uh june was for
the low
it's two percent ahead of plan and for
the high
it is 13 of head of plan which is um
the average historic performance of
revenue for may and june so if you think
it's going to
be above that um above that average
then i think your number is fine we we
felt comfortable with the average being
our high
um but 10 to 12 million is not
out of almost a billion dollars is not
off all that much
mr chairman yes
i think there's a problem with that high
methodology now because
on part of april ended up being in june
i'm not sure what the effect which
effect that has in which direction
yeah and then the 29
i i had in closing anomalies
so um the average for 11 months
is less than that take the anomaly out
okay we could drop that down closer to
20 percent
so maybe the 20 sounds like a reasonable
number
20 percent is 9.85 right
yes
representative tudor you have your hand
up i was just curious if the dra could
tell us
um how well june is tracking is june
tracking
uh way well above their projection
through the first 10 days here or can
they had mentioned it but melissa would
you respond to that
yeah it's a little um what i did state
is that we are tracking ahead of last
year we do know last year was a little
bit of an
anomalous um it is definitely too early
to say
what it looks like compared to our
numbers and that's just because the bulk
of the revenue i mean we're
we're in the eighth and the bulk of the
revenue hasn't come in all i can say is
the small amount that has come in
has been higher than last year at this
point
yeah chris would you put up the may
revenue focus
she shows the plan
all right and go to the i think page
four
yep
okay and then just reduce it a little
okay notice that on page four the
total business taxes came in 29.1
more than the
11 months of plan but then
in that 29.1
is the 18.2 million dollars
that's the anomaly that should that
should be removed
to look at the new percentage
they took the anomaly out
we need to take the anomaly out of this
percentage and they already did see
below
yeah no but but that they took it as one
they took the whole anomaly out to 30.8
million out at the bottom
you know but they didn't take it out and
exactly correct sorry yeah
so the anomaly is in the number of 848.1
and every one percent is six and a half
million so
so it would bring this down to about 26
all right so it still is 988 million
representative romney you don't agree
all right i mean
i feel more comfortable to 985 but 98
fine
i'd be fine with the 985 also
i will i think yeah that's
yeah 95 then okay okay
who would not be comfortable with the
and you're going to lower your hand
representative romney
oh my hands up sorry
we move forward one slot so the
base for fy21 for the house ways and
now
we have two ways to go we can do fy21
all the way down
or we can
finish the estimates for for the
business taxes
going across the road to 22 and 23.
yeah and uh and this is gonna be the
most difficult one
so it'd be better if we get out of the
way
good that represent
yes my thought is from all the comments
i've heard and i've only been here 10
minutes
um i think maybe the estimates
would all end up with wider ranges just
because of all the unknowns
but i'm still wondering in the end if we
would end up in the middle
near the same place so that's just what
i've been thinking i mean there
are more unknowns every time we talk um
but some of them will boost it up and
someone will boost it down
so it does sound like the range is wider
with all the questions we have right now
but will the middle still be the same as
my thought for this morning
we will find out yeah okay
so we're going to run with 985 million
for fy21
now we go on to fy 22 from the business
taxes
so that brings us to the norm that
brings us to the discussion of
now offline do we want to adjust
down the base or not not not the base
that we're going to show
we're going to move forward from whether
or not that's anomalous as one way of
handling the
that's going to be a hard number to come
by but you're right
because that's going to start showing up
at 522
is because what's happening now
or has happened during this whole year
isn't going to continue to be happening
as far as
economic support from all the stimuluses
or for the economic
attack because of this the pandemic
is not going to happen
we're hoping next year so that
we have to make an adjustment to that
but the only problem i have
norm is i have no idea how to do that
nobody does
yeah i mean this is
it'd be guess work on our part we know
we know it's
this year is artificially high but
um you know by by how much
uh we don't know and correct me if i'm
wrong uh
melissa i think i think
dra took the position that that these
revenues
that we just projected are are actually
pretty real
if you will and you are in your minds
because you you
you never when you did your you didn't
adjust those down at all
like help me out i remember you saying
something somewhere along the line
melissa can i let's answer that question
norm
uh melissa you have a response
sure um yeah we've we've looked at a lot
of
of different items um it's definitely a
hard year to predict
um but we have
taken so far of just doing a growth
um between two and six percent we have
not adjusted down the base
um we don't have we really are data
driven and we don't have
any data to show
that there's anomalous revenue that
won't continue
into the next couple of years
however if you feel differently feel
free to adjust them but at this point we
have kept our fiscal year 21
range the same and then we grew 22 off
of that
off of that range it did not make any
um before we go
forward i want to hear get some
additional input uh representative
murphy followed by representative
spillsbury representative murphy
thank you um i guess somewhat of a
simple question but maybe
a thought about projecting to the future
which is i think going to be the most
difficult part as we have all talked
about
it would seem like you have the bulk of
the information already in for 21 and so
those numbers
would seem to be appropriate and real it
would also seem difficult to
use that base number as the launch pad
for
projecting 22-23 given all
the confounding factors that we have
talked about
some of them are permanent and some of
them are going to go away
such as the infusion of dollars and the
sb 3 and ppp effect so my question is
how inappropriate or realistic would it
be
to use 21
or 2021 as a asterisk
phenomenon and as has been mentioned
before
not use the 21 numbers as the base
in projecting going forward but actually
back up a bit to 19 and 20
and then see if you could extrapolate
from those numbers what it might look
like
based on what the known permanent
changes may be
market-based sourcing or credit carry
forward that we know about
because obviously many of the
adjustments and the
uh confounding factors secondary to
covid are going to be
hopefully temporary in nature so my
question would be i guess this would be
for the
you know melissa and chris whoever
could you use 19 and 20 as the base in a
sense
and project out increased percentages
going forward so
um i'm just they're just some of those
thoughts
thank you so i guess my response would
be um
represent major and represent murphy is
that you can use whatever methodology
that the committee feels is appropriate
to come up with a base number that you
think is the most correct or the best
estimate that the committee can
make so if you need to go back and look
at 19 and 20 to see what was going on
in in those two years that's certainly
an option um you know dra has a
as melissa indicated they are data
driven so they use
information that um they can grab out of
the system and see what's happened along
with some
trending that that they also see um
so yeah the answer is it's however the
committee decides they want to make an
estimate you could make an estimate
of a flat number as well if you wanted
to just say that
i'm in 22 we think it's going to be 990
million
and just just say that the reason for
that is
based on all the uncertainties and and
the pluses and minuses we don't think
that there's really
a good base to apply to 22 um and we
think it's going to fall around this
number so so there's a
whatever methodology the committee would
like or as an individual you would like
to
come up with a number to debate with the
committee
and i don't know if melissa wants to add
or subtract from what i might have said
um i'll quiet down
yeah nope i think chris said it
perfectly um we're just here to give our
thoughts and information on it but it
is 100 the committee's um estimates that
they get to use and how they come up
with
them is is their choice we're just
trying to give as much information as we
have and what we think but
if you guys feel differently um feel
free to choose
what you would what you would think
okay representative stillsbury yes thank
you mr chairman
i very much appreciate melissa's
explanation
that they are data driven and therefore
limited in terms of how to approach this
in the way that we would so we have
freedom
uh maybe this goes uh somewhat in the
same direction from a different angle is
representative murphy i just
if you look at the senate's projection
they came out for fy 22
with a 3.57 increase so
uh a little bit below the middle of
dra's two to six
percent range if we just blindly applied
that
which frankly i think is what the senate
has done
to our new base of 985 for fy21
that would lead us to a figure for fy22
of 1020.16
in other words a billion 20 million
and i think that just illustrates that
that approach is leading us astray
rather than focusing on fy20 on the new
figure of 985 for fy21
let's go back to our march 18th
projection for fy22 which was 847.7
and the commonality here with
representative murphy's thinking is that
our 847.7 was in fact
based largely on what had occurred in 19
and 20.
uh as squishy as the information might
be
whether there's grounds to raise 847.7
how brief are these anomalies
well can i react to that norm um
or is it somebody else stand up for well
yeah as i approach this i see
fy22 in a different light than fy23
um i think uh in fy
22 there'll be federal money still
pouring into our
our new hampshire economy the harp of
money
is uh about to be distributed
and that's a lot of money um and so
i'm i'm optimistic in terms of revenue
going forward for the next 12 months
[Music]
basically because of that subject to the
adjustment for
refunds that we've talked about the pvp
refunds
and if i were projecting um
i think what i would favor is taking the
new number that we've been
we're in the process of developing uh
well for business taxes taking the new
number we've talked about for fy21
and taking out of it the expected ppp
refund and then growing it
perhaps at the same growth rate that
the dra i'd use 3.5 7
if i have that right um
[Music]
and um that would give us a number to
for fy 22 and maybe i
i should stop there i think the idea of
trying to
identify a base that's appropriate to
use
is a really difficult one the idea of
looking back
in time looking back to where where we
were when we were doing this estimating
work
earlier this year maybe
may be helpful but i would separate the
two fiscal years i guess that's my
contribution
and if you do that
the ppp effect
is 25.4 million and that's why
222 and then we reduced our base number
it's a good reason because that's gonna
that's gonna happen
to that amount of money anyway
uh i had identified representative elmi
and then followed by representative
romney
thank you uh the arpa money which is
is a huge amount of money coming and the
question
is where is it actually going to be used
a lot of
it is on
up to subdivisions of the state a lot of
that is going to be
infrastructure kinds of things that
could
but may not permanently help the economy
and and make us grow faster
on we can't tell yet on
and a lot of it may get used
for on most of
our businesses in the state of new
hampshire since
almost all of our businesses are what
so it's it's
really difficult we can't possibly
disentangle what that stimulus
is going to leave us with on
in 23 as it's reducing but as
it's also adding
infrastructure in our state for the
roads to be better for broadband to be
better for that kind of thing
if that actually works that would be a
stimulus in itself which would be
showing up mostly in 23
what i wanted i think we should take
out the ppp money
um and i think that
we should also take out something for
the single sales factor
unless we can get some uh
idea from dra about whether they
are far enough along that they think
they're successful in finding
enough money outside the state to
replace what we're going to lose inside
this state
and and i think that
that we ought to take off a bit more
than the ppp money because people got
main street money and a whole bunch of
other things that we don't know about
because the governor wasn't telling
people
okay um representative
if we take fy21
and remove the ppp money
you're down to 959.6 million dollars and
then if you go
to the mid-range
what the dra came up with two to six
percent and say it's four percent
growth at four percent growth on that
you would have 998
which should be it exceeds
fy21 but it makes
um buy
uh 13 million dollars
but to me i forgot who
recommended that i think norma that puts
us right at what the senate is at
they're at 997.8
it does it does you didn't miracles
happen
he didn't realize that to me
that makes sense i mean i mean you could
do
many different things but
to grab something
that you can understand and we do know
we're going to lose that 25 25.4 million
dollars
maybe even more so we need to remove
that from our base
and then grow that new base by
if you go up by four percent and we'll
that's my number somebody else want
another number
and reason why mr chairman could we
ask the dra whether they've got any
further guidance on
what single sales factor is going to do
to us
because they've they've killed that bill
again
and yeah we haven't it's going to happen
yeah we haven't gone into the uh
changes to current law yeah i would
rather stick with the
current law and then and then after we
get through
the current law but it is current law
they put it in current law in the last
budget
but i'm just remembering now it's only
going to affect us in 23.
and we're doing 22 right now
does anybody have a different
mythology or a different number
for fy22 and let me just repeat that
again we take the
fy 21 number reduce it by the ppp
amount of refunds which is 25.4 million
come up with 959 million
and then raise that by four percent the
middle of the growth range
and we come up with 998 million dollars
which
within 200 000 of the senate number
are you okay with that number i i
i second that number yeah i do too
and that's who's not okay with that
number
okay going once twice and three times
million for fy22
now we go to fy23 that's why 23
by 23 we also need to take into
there's going to be 40 an extra 44
million dollars
mr chairman is that 44 is that 44 minus
because we took it off of the base
before
that's in the uh right right right
it's it should be 19.
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait um
there's going to be a lot more refunds
and uh less
quarterly payments than the prior year
i mean well i wouldn't subtract the two
that 44 million is what it is it is but
we already removed
the first one from the 25 from the base
oh i see what you mean let me think
about this yeah
so it's the difference between those
is
when it comes to small numbers it's
tough
so we would reduce
the base we would reduce
and then put a growth factor on
yes
um chris help me out would we consider
that
so if you look at the screen now you see
where the changes the current law
are you go down to the fifth row up
it's payroll protection program you have
the house assuming the senate assumed
25.4 million dollars and 22 and 44
million dollars and 23
reduction to your your revenues right
so so they're already accounting for
that so they developed a base just as
you guys did
last um back in march
and then you go and you make reductions
based on
changes to law that's being proposed
this session
okay so they one of the changes that
they
the senate had compared to the house is
the single sales
the house language was included to delay
that so there was a positive 20 million
dollar gain
carried on the surplus statement the
senate removed that language
um so there's no there's no adjustment
you can see that right here right and so
okay
so that's in their numbers the 20
yes so so they didn't give them because
they removed their
the the position of the house which was
to delay the single sales
they didn't take credit for 20 million
dollars they actually
lose the 20 million dollars in the final
number
so their final number of uh excuse me
right here 102 9.6
um their final number becomes 2
2 8 0 1.6 and 22 after they make all the
adjustments
that you see on this page that's on your
screen right now right
but but their business taxes that they
come up with for final for 23
1 0 to 9.6
takes that into account so
similar to how the house did it back in
march they made estimates
and then growth to those estimates and
debated um
why they thought the numbers should be
what they are to go with current law
and that's what you have before you
that's the 963 and 21 the 997 and 22
and the 10 29 and 23. and then
um the senate ways and means considered
some of the adjustments
uh to current law
that were contained in house bill 2 and
that was the
and so that that nets against the the
revenue so if you were to go through
and grab all the business related
adjustments you would apply that against
the base number up above
but what they're saying is that they're
not going to lose
any money off of the single sales factor
being in place
what they're saying is that it's already
been considered in the base numbers
because that's current law
the house position was you were delaying
it so you were going to gain 20 million
dollars
because we delayed it right but
their position is that we're not going
to lose anything
from the sales factor no that's uh their
position is it's already been considered
it wasn't because it was susan it was
our bill
our bill we passed our bill in the house
that
would delay the single sales factor
they voted that down by the time we did
our estimates
we we said we were going to gain 20
million dollars because of our bill
delaying single sales factor because
yeah
they did their estimates 20 million
so i i understand now what you're saying
it was there because we thought the
senate was going to pass our bill
or that was the assumption yep did not
pass our bill
so it went away and they
went away but we still lose money with
single sales
factor uh and i thought 20 million was a
minimum
that we okay they didn't have to
consider it because they
they considered it when they did their
base
numbers because it was
current law for them correct
um represents spellsbury
followed by representative ames thank
you mr chairman so
uh understanding what's just been
discussed we're
groping for the current law figure so
the ppp
refunds are dealt with separately on
those adjustments
for change in law but that still brings
us back to
representative ames point which is that
we've got to view f y 22 and f y 23
differently from the perspective of how
uh how much longer a stimulus
particularly with the new flow of arpa
is going to be goosing things so
do i i think the case has been clearly
made that there's still going to be a
strong stimulus effect in fy 22
unless we believe that that's also true
for fy 23
we should not just simply escalate again
and in this case it looks like the
senate is bumped
23 over 22 by 3.19
so i don't know how to come up with that
number but it does seem to me there
should be a tapering
of the stimulus impact coming towards us
by
fy23
so i think as your committee heard um
the
stimulus money is available until 24.
federal fiscal year 24 and if it's
encumbred the
entities may be able to have it for a
longer period
so i believe the um there was some of
that consideration
when the senate was looking at their 23
figure
but um that would be certainly a
discussion that um any committee a
conference
or or with the chairs of the two ways
yeah um i agree with much of what's just
been said
but before we
before we jump into
what the growth factor should be for
fy23
i think we need to wrap up what we're
growing from and
i think we we agree that the new base
that we set for fy23 is the starting
point
that we need to take out of it the ppp
money
and then the question raised by
representative omni is is still on the
table because
do we think that
the going to the single sales factor
loss or revenue loss effect
and if we do that's
current law we're dealing with current
law here that's all
then should we take that out
so we get the base that we want to use
for
applying the growth factor that we need
to
identify which i think consistent with
what representative spillsbury just said
has to be lower than
fy22 but i'm
really in the dark as to how much lower
much of what
representative alame said is absolutely
true
there may be essence maybe a different
kind of
flow of that money into the economy that
may be
showing its impact a little later
there's that aspect
and we really don't know that we also i
think have to be informed by what
chris jay said about arpa money it
doesn't have to be
spent until what is that four years out
um
and uh so so it's a really hard nut to
crack on the growth factor
the lifestyle is lower than three point
whatever
uh that we were using in 22.
so so the first thing to me anyway is is
putting behind us the question of um
the opera money that's committed
by december of 24
and push their money out on this
when the senate came up with a 1.029
i wouldn't i would have felt that they
it wasn't explicitly discussed they went
with their current law
estimates and i think the assumption was
that um when they were looking at the
base numbers that were
provided that that was weaved into it
but they did have a a robust discussion
therefore chris they they assume that
there's no impact either way
going to single sales factor probably
i think that's probably their position
this is revenue neutral to them
and and i can't uh suggest your
position their position to you i don't
know i mean i it would be all
speculative on my part
i'm speculating uh that since they
really haven't discussed it
they went through their methodology as
they normally would
uh assuming that there's no impact
on us on the revenues
because it's a single sales factor our
position is that we still suspect that
there's going to be some downward
revenue um but that's something we
need to discuss if we still want to hold
on to that
our position on that and we but we can't
show that in the
in the uh surplus statement anymore
because it is now
current law that we're projecting
uh which includes includes
single sass factor so we we would have
to adjust the base somewhere or
or our percentages or something we
reflect that
at 20 million dollars if you will so
try something we came up with 998
million dollars at 522
we know we're going to have to
reduce the base by
44 million dollars because of tpp
by 23. but in there is already the 24
point something
so i would say that we would have to
reduce the 998 by 18.6 million dollars
what would be 979.4
and if you use four percent it would end
up
being one billion eighteen million
point six dollars six thousand dollars
what 1.018.6
billion dollars which would be
about 11 million dollars less than what
the senate
has
we in our committee agreed
that on first
it depends how much we're going to lose
depends entirely
on how much of our huge
businesses the ones that pay most of our
business profit stacks
are on manufacturers
the manufacturers are going to stop
on it was set at 20 million bank
when we thought we were going to get a
lot less money
in general uh
if we don't take out at least something
for the loss through single sales factor
then then we're agreeing with the senate
that it's revenue neutral
and maybe you want to do that
fortunately we have no idea what the
total loss is going to be
but we settled on 20 million dollars
we could do more and probably
the possibility of being less isn't that
great
so at this point
let's go back we still have a starting
point of 998 million dollars
we need to adjust for the ppp
and that would be 18.6 that brings us to
979.4
if we say the growth rate in 23 from
22's four percent that's the number i
came up with 1.018
that's leaving now with the 20 million
dollars
off of that then we would be nine
ninety
okay a ninety eight wait a minute yeah
i'm looking at back at 9.98 right
979 0.4
uh that's after backing out to 18.6
yep then times 1.04
that's yeah 1018 uh
right so still still under right well
well under the
senate and if we took 20 million dollars
off that we end up with 9.98
998.6 call it yes
and we aren't growing the 20 million by
two years of
uh representative spellsbury yes thank
you mr chairman i'm not sure exactly
where you ended there but
when we've taken out the incremental uh
ppp and got to 979.4
um or whether we adjust that back to 998
i don't
i would refrain from going higher
personally i just think that we should
resolve
uncertainty conservatively and maybe
level it well
taking out the 20 million dollars does
that yeah
but i i'm saying 998 rather than a
million 29 or something in between
the we need to account for
the single sales factor it's how much
and i think i think the conservative
point is 20 million dollars
and that would show there'd be no growth
from one year to the other but that's
there's a reason for that because we're
giving out a lot of
refunds and then number two
going to the single sales factor a lot
of people not paying the business
i wonder what the number would be if we
went to three percent growth
is uh 1.08.8
1 billion
that's before the 20 million that's
before the
20 million and then take the 20 million
well i'm i'm i'm more comfortable going
in that direction
than at the four percent growth rate for
the reasons i
said before um it could be between three
and four i'd like to see at a lower
growth rate than
uh fy22 so that came
out to be nine
[Music]
can we just split the difference norm
can we split the difference oh
hold on a minute because we still have a
couple of hands okay representing the
model
thank you a very basic question but i
i don't understand why we're not taking
the whole 44
million out for ppp in year 2023 can
well when you take the 18.6
in the 25.4 it adds up to 44.
i understand that it just seems like
it's
what's been estimated that we're going
to be giving back each year
and it's not a cumulative thing so it
seems like
not not each year the
24 point 25.4
is for 22 then it goes to 44.
then the next year i believe it goes to
a smaller number and then it tapers to
almost nothing
right of
revenue that we're returning to
businesses
each year you want to answer that
cumulative i'm sorry yeah
so i i believe uh repsome grammar is
correct
the information that you had was that it
was going to be a 25.4 million dollar
hit
in 22 right and then in 23 it was 44 and
then it tapered down to 19.2
4.1 and down to 1.7 by 2028 for a total
impact
of 99.4 million dollars
so we should be taking the whole 44
i believe that would be um the correct
way to do it unless melissa
jumps in and tells me i'm giving you
incorrect information
25 in the base
melissa would you uh comment on it
please
sure and i'll also have carolyn jump in
if i misspeak because she's
a little bit of an expert on this part
um i believe because you took the 25 out
of the base
it's the difference between the 25 and
the 44. the 44 is compared to 21.
so um if you would have just
done the four percent growth and then
took in the 20 taking the 25 out after
like it is on the surplus statement
then it would be the 44 but because you
took the 25.4
out of the 22 base before you grew 23
you're already accounting for part of
that so you just do the 18.6
got it that makes sense i get it thank
you very much
thank you melissa you're welcome thank
hey we've got all the important people
here
uh okay so then
if we take i think representative
spillsbury has his hand up yeah
okay i'm sorry representative
spillsbourne
uh if i do i'm sorry i didn't lower it
and remove the 18.6 because we already
had removed 25.4
we got 979.4
1.018 and if we grow it
at 3 percent and remove the 20 million
dollars
we'll end up with 988.7 million dollars
how does the committee feel with that i
think
i'd like to split the difference between
your original 998.6 and the 988.7
and i'd like to point out that if we
take
the 20 million out at the end it has
the 20 million has grown as those
companies have
so representative romney
recommending that we
3.7 yep 993.7
yep
representative major representative
representative
i have a question for representative
abrami yes sir
uh what will be the effect
if inflation continues to grow on the
three to four percent
uh outlook that we're thinking these
businesses are going to uh
well i i if it's inflation it means the
prices are going up i
i
i i haven't answered that question
we are faced with potential of inflation
here
um basically the old adage of too many
dollars chasing too
few goods with the much revenue into the
system right now
is is putting pressure on inflation
there's no question
i don't know the answer to your question
though uh
a follow-up question uh mr chairman to
uh
the dra uh melissa
uh representative schamberg here has
there been
any data that you've been able to gather
in comparison
uh with single sales factor to what
we're
i'm actually gonna pass that off to
carolyn she's the ah
okay all right factor expert
warning representatives carolyn lear
assistant commissioner at the department
of revenue
um so just to back up a step or two
um to remind this country the reason why
we're unable to
estimate the impact of single sales
factor
at the moment is because of the recent
implementation of market-based sourcing
which will result in really changing
who our taxpayers are in some instances
market-based sourcing was effective on
1 121. um
yeah i'm sorry 1120 i'm sorry um
and those returns would have been filed
for the first time
this spring um but as you know
given the pandemic the delayed due date
um and the just huge number of taxpayers
that we have
filing on extension um
those return we just don't have that
return
data yet that we would need to sort of
take a look at our new taxpayer base and
then make an
additionally of course you know our
largest taxpayers
are fiscal year taxpayers and
their returns are even more delayed
and so we really won't have um
a sufficient number of returns
for probably at least six maybe 12
months to really come up with a good
number for you folks on single sales
factor
when believe it was 1120 but now i am
second guessing myself single sales
factor is 1
122. january
um yes but the the market-based sourcing
change which is really the
sort of root of why we don't have great
data for you on single sales factor i
believe was 1
so we just don't have those returns in
any meaningful number yet to tell you
to then run the single sales factor
analysis on those new taxpayers
to come up with an accurate analysis
so do you know enough to uh give us an
idea
of where the vector would be heading
i i think that's a tough question i have
up
our most recent analysis which
um i believe you've all seen which gives
you
sort of a picture of what it would have
been
in tax years 2014 through 2018
um in two of those years single sales
factor
actually results in more revenue
but in three years it results in
substantially less revenue
um so if you're looking at the average
you're probably looking at a reduction
in revenue
um attributable to single sales factor
the effective date of single sales
factor um
is 1122 um so you would start to see
that um that impact
in estimate payments being filed in the
spring
of 22.
mr chairman could i just ask carolyn
another question go ahead representative
yes uh for market-based sourcing you
were having to go
and find the businesses outside the
state that
now under market-based sourcing is
supposed to be paying us money that
weren't paying us money before do you
have any idea whether
on your finding enough of them
to make up the money on that change
which might give us some idea of whether
we could
could find the money from outside to
make up the money on the single sales
factor change
far too early currently to have been
to be conducting audit activities on
market-based sourcing
we really have to wait to see if
taxpayers voluntarily file
and then we won't start looking for them
until they don't voluntarily file
okay at this point in time
because of the information that was
conveyed to us
we're not sure how much it's going to
impact
us we do know that it's going to impact
us
negatively and that we're start up
and we have used 20 million dollars as a
negative impact
i don't see how we could come up with
a number any better than that
because we're really taking something
out of the air
i i would go along with the 20 million
right
representative tucker has her hand up uh
yes i want to
comment on the
topic of inflation everything i've been
reading
agrees that there is an inflationary
trend at the moment
but many experts believe it will
subside by the end of the year i think
that
the topic of inflation has become a very
partisan one
and probably better something for us to
avoid getting
involved in right on these estimates
i remind everybo uh carolyn
the market-based sourcing really only
impacts
service companies correct
and it's so it's not the full population
of all companies that it's going to
impact
but someone who provides a service
to and it depends on where the service
is being provided from
current law was like let's use the ala
physio example
i was brokering stuff to maine
he was paying our tax he was paying the
new hampshire tax
but then maine put a market-based source
again that made him pay the tax
twice he had to pay the tax domain as
well
so we changed that so now with
market-based sourcing
uh it it's aldo tizio no longer pays the
tax
but the person that he's providing the
service to
will be taxed in that state
uh so the receiver of the service is
going to pay the tax not the provider of
the service
representative you're correct that
market-based sourcing only
impacts um the sale of
services of intangibles um and
i would just modify your last statement
a bit
it doesn't impact who pays the tax it
just
impacts where the tax is paid so in the
main
new hampshire example previously new
hampshire would have
taxed a service provider in new
hampshire if they were located in new
hampshire
that's a bit of an oversimplification
but for our purposes works
and now we wouldn't tax that revenue
because we would instead look to the
location of
the provider's customer um which in our
example was maine
and that's then that's susan uh
represent almi's thing is that
that's still at issue is that we have to
find these companies
that are receiving the service to be
able to
send them a tax bill exactly okay
we know that we have a lot to learn
about
market-based source and single sales
factor
what effect it's going to have on our
revenue we don't have enough information
yet to know exactly what's going to
happen
our discussion is
do we use the 20 million dollars or do
we have
i'm getting there and so
that's where we are at this point in
time representatives
yeah um thank you i i
i would take the 20 million dollars i
think it's the best we got
where they deduct um i think
we were at a point in the discussion
before we
dove into a single sales factor
where we had two numbers two possible
numbers
in front of us and one was
a four percent growth factor uh on a
base that excluded the ppp money
and then after getting a number we
subtracted
20 million that's what i remember and
then
okay there was a suggestion that we
um go halfway
to something i don't remember what the
something was
it was 993.7 million dollars and that's
using
a three percent growth factor okay to
that one
um and uh what i'd like to
know if our math gurus can tell us is uh
going to that midpoint
implies what growth factor um
you know it's not four percent it's not
three percent it's somewhere in between
isn't it halfway in between 3.5
right so it should be 1.35
1.035
can i jump up on my norm can i jump in
please
uh yes yeah i think he misspoke it's uh
your original uh number was 998.6
yes representative ames number was 988.7
at the 3
so i would assume that would be three
and a half percent
uh does anybody have a different number
are we
with the explanation that we use the
base
of 2022 reduced it by 18.6 million
dollars
three and three and a half percent and
remove 20 million dollars because of
the same the sales factor is going
is continuing going to continuous
current law
it just puts me beyond where i think
this moderate range should be um it
really does but
i'll support the uh to me
all right now chris you have the numbers
all right 985 for 21
okay and your numbers for 22 and 23
already account for the ppp say that
again
your numbers for 22 and 23 already
account for the
and 20 so does that put us above the
senate
so the senate base number doesn't back
out the 25 point
two million dollars or the forty four
point zero million dollars
so yes i believe it puts you higher than
the senate
but now all we have to do is is
but yep
which let's let's just take a quick look
at uh
so you've you've accounted for the
payroll protection program
yeah the senate
doesn't do that until after so that they
have a negative adjustment of 25.4 and
and a negative adjustment of 44 million
dollars and 23
from their base number well we didn't
have an adjustment
when we did it in march correct
right so we picked up
and the senate used the numbers that we
worked with with the dra and we're using
it now
okay so
uh the sweat reduction
is the same the uh historic
racing is the same yep and we took care
of single sales factor
uh everything else is the same going to
the top
except for the additional dra auditor
right the the uh
senate finance committee did not add the
two positions that the house finance
committee
had recommended which then would impact
the three million dollars in revenue
that
mr chairman representative tudor
should shouldn't the 20 million come out
of the single sales factor on this sheet
well it's going to come out
no because it's in current law right
yeah we have to foreign 20 million out
based on the fact that we
we thought the senate was going to pass
what we our bill they did not pass our
bill
yeah that doesn't matter when we take
that 20 million
going above the payroll protection
program
until you get to the top
and that was the auditors
so we would be in agreement with the
senate
the uh the other thing we were
different is the senate came up with a
which sets the meals and rooms
tax takes 30 percent
after uh paying administrative costs and
some other thing sending 30 percent
to a special dedicated fund
managed by the treasury and not
managed by the finance committee
and to be distributed to the towns and
cities
which is about 50 million dollars more
we would have to get an agreement on
that
chairman the result of this is that
we're going to have an abrupt
dip in the reporting
of the meals and rooms fund
it's going to be at 70 of what it was
before
so even though it's not a total 30
that's going to the municipalities the
way they're handling this
if we do this dedicated fund is that uh
most of uh 30 of the rooms and meals
revenue that we've been
right right now we send i think around
20 something percent
is it right uh the the percentage varies
from year to year so the
the meals and rooms distribution has
been
um suspended or controlled
over for the last decade by the
legislature so
in in statute it the intention was to
let it grow to 40 percent over time
and it was a five million dollar cap per
year and the growth of that fund
or that distribution but since the
fiscal year 2010 the legislature has
decided
a figure that it would appropriate and
that would be distributed due to various
reasons
um this year the governor's proposed
budget was to increase it
to 73.6 million dollars and 22
and 78 point um million dollars in
23. so he was going and he didn't
suspend the language
that allowed for that growth the senate
plan was to say
let's move that all off into a
restricted fund
let's make the amount equal to 30
take it out of the the budget debate so
that the
communities would be getting the the
distribution
um without it becoming something that
budget negotiators
would tweak in order to get dollars that
they might want
to save or to spend we don't see the
full
effect of that because we're already
transferring
around 25 could be 21 or something like
that
so it's the difference between that and
the 30
yep and then so that's why
over the course of the biennium they're
going to be getting
an extra 50 something million dollars
just distributed to the towns and cities
mr chairman because of the dedicated
fund provision that they put in
on the monthly revenue focus starting in
july i believe
maybe august is going to show set
30 percent less revenue in rooms and
meals than there was before
minus that five cents that the governor
put in
uh right
because now it's taken out
in no longer versus the budget process
can i speak to this yes dr
names um i think this is an important
important question but it's not
directly related to our the task that's
before us
we need we need right now we've got
we're looking at a picture that shows
the education and
general fund combined so uh we're seeing
pretty much
the whole picture but not quite because
there are a few things that have been
um sent off outside of this picture that
we're looking at
and now we're talking about another
send-off of a big
chunk of money to another fund
and to me the answer to this problem is
to
widen the pitch the frame of our picture
as we go forward and i think it's a
different discussion but when we
are estimating revenues we're going to
have to look at the rooms and meals tax
as a whole and then
divvy it up just as we do with the
business tax right now
and part of the divine is to a new fund
which i hope
will become part of the picture we're
looking at when we
do this whole thing and it is done in
such a way that people can see
continuity
from before the establishment of a
separate fund
for meals and room local
sharing whatever you call it um
and after it's just a matter of doing it
right
i don't know whether it can be done
administratively or whether it's going
to require legislation but i hope we can
try to try to do it in a way that
allows people to see what's happened
over a period of years and also allows
us to do our job
right we're still going to have to
estimate the total
meals and rooms tax knowing that
the rooms and meals tax that we collect
for
car rental that's taken off
and sent to the education trust fund
now we have the 30 of
what's left after administrative costs
and the
distributed distribution for the
education trust fund 30 of what's left
then goes to the special dedicated fund
and then what's left goes to the general
fund but we need to know
the total number right
that's another exercise
but when you look at this
table what we see
the senate took out the
addition of the two auditors and
therefore
we will not see that revenue and
everything else and then also they took
out
a single sales factor
if you don't agree with me no we're okay
with this
now the payroll protection we're going
to we're okay with that because we're
going to use the same
25.4 and the 44 in our revenue estimates
the dedicated fund for the 30
uh chris we we need to have
broken down the total mills and rooms
tax
and then what goes what gets siphoned
off
and then what's left that goes out to 30
so the 90 the negative 92.6 and 95.6
is the estimated amount that would come
out of the base
meals and rooms up above which allows
for
um the the transfer to the education
trust fund so that's considered in the
formula
yeah i i thought the 30
came after they removed the
subscription to the uh the car rental
yes education and after they removed the
administrative costs
yep okay and it's and it's based on the
prior year's revenue
yes so your distribution in 22 is based
on your 21 revenue
yes okay
on mr chairman yes i think
we're double counting or rather double
deducting
on the payroll protection program at
this point
and it would be simpler if we agreed
to on the
that the house would agree to put 25
and 44 in to 22
and 23. and then
we added those back into our revenue
estimates
because you're going to have to be going
back and forth with the senate
about oh we had the 25 over there
i thought we were using those as just a
way of reducing the base
for lack of anything else to use to
estimate
what we thought the revenues were going
to be because i i
i think we should show it the way it's
showing here then so it's going to seem
like a double
count here but a double reduction
but um i think
i think this is the proper way of
dealing with this so 25.4 and the 44
is is coming out but
i agree if we stay with this
are we saying that we're going to uh
increase
what we came up with by 25.4 and 44.
i i don't think because yes
can you get can you square us away on
this
so i i agree that with representative
almi in the sense that they'll
you're going to have some confusion when
you try to present this to the senate
because they're going to be looking at
the current revenue number
and they're going to say our number is
997.8 and your number is 9.98 so we
agree
just saying well what they may not know
and may not get explained is that
you've already accounted for the ppp and
then you may end up with a
double reduction because it would be
showing up lower in the
adjustments for um changes that are
so i mean it depends on
how this is going to be presented to um
the
senate ways and means and the debate or
discussion that's going to occur
um i understand what you're trying to do
in terms of
you know bring your base down which you
you've kind of adjusted and then you can
say okay add the 25 back to the 98
make a negative adjustment below yeah
but it or you can leave it the way you
have it and then you can
just be clear when it's explained to the
committee the senate members that
you've already accounted for the ppp in
your number
i could these are one-time payments
and so maybe it's a lot easier to
i agree i think it should be in the
surplus statement yeah
which is what these figures in this
second sheet
yeah that's where they go those all end
up in the surplus statement that's where
these
so if you were to do a house
adjustment we
because you've already included or taken
care of it up above
i don't believe we would still show zero
well the only reason is there's zero
there
we haven't gotten that far right i
understood
of 998 and 22 and 993
and 0.7 and 23
that's already accounted for the 25.4
million of the
payroll protection in 22 and then you
adjusted because you reduced your base
in 22 you reduced
23 by 18.6
yeah i can see if
if we were appears and used current law
we wouldn't be showing that adjustment
base numbers would be higher and then
on here the payroll protection you'd see
the 25
4 and the 44 the adjustment
because it's still not current why that
even though we passed it in the senate
has the governor signed it
um i don't know i don't know so
it's not current line yet so we need to
actually show it in our revenue numbers
and then adjust it by
putting it on the payroll protection
changes to current law mr
chairman we've got a long-term
policy of when a bill passes
the the house or the senate the house or
the senate
can include it as current law in the
budget
stuff
that's the case
uh chris i'm going to rely on you
it's the proper method i would suggest
even if it's signed into law before a
committee a conference is held that you
still treat it as if it hasn't
it's not in your base current law
numbers that you have it separated out
on a surplus statement
and that way and that way you have a a
place to go
to look back on to see what did you
adjust for
if it's buried in the in the number
um the base number up above or the
current law number up above
it would be harder to trace back what
you accounted or what you
estimated would be the impact of the
change
let us do it that way so
you would add 25.4 million back to 22
and 18.6 million back to 23 and then
show a negative adjustment
below at 25 4 and 44. yes
and then and then then that would
then everything to be shown in the
bottom line
adjustments
mr chairman i've had my hand up to try
and weigh in on this uh representative
yeah thank you um correct me if i'm
wrong but i think we're going astray
this looks like a double adjustment
but it's not the purpose
of the offsets
uh based on law changes
is to refund monies already collected in
fy 21 and already in
our fy21 estimate
the purpose of reducing
the base for the purpose of growing
the 22 and 23 numbers
is to make sure that those funds that
will be refunded next year
i actually agree with that by the way
that's where i was trying to go with
this
yes that's what that's what
representative abrami was saying and i
agree with it
you know well but you said it more
eloquently
[Laughter]
i think we i think we we subtracted uh
we put in the surplus statement to minus
25 and the minus 44
and keep our revenues the way they are
as we predict okay
is that what you're saying to mr
representative
yeah that's precisely what i'm saying
okay and chris are you all right with
that
i'm i'm fine with whatever the committee
wants to do that's fine it makes sense
it's if that's you just need to make
sure that it gets communicated
if there's if you if there's any
confusion on what's happening that's all
right um but the suggestion would is
that you you've made your adjustments
you're going to have a number of 998 and
22 a number of 993.7 and 23
and that you would agree that you should
show on a surplus statement
a negative adjustment of 25.4 and 22 and
fine i'm asking i just want to make sure
that's
what i'm understanding representative
spillsbury and representative abrami and
ames
representative that captures it exactly
chris thank you yep
thank you okay then the
only other change is in the last
line before the bold
is the additional transfer to the
education trust fund
um you want to do the brick explanation
on that
question so the lottery commission um
purchased the building that it currently
is in and so they were paying a mortgage
on that they got permission from the
legislature i think two budgets ago to
do that
um the thought was and and the section
has been added to uh house bill 2 to
actually pay off that mortgage
and as a result the um mortgage payments
that of
about 200 000 each year would then
be transferred into the education trust
fund instead of being used to
pay the mortgage so that's where that
all right it says mr chairman
so the house is not going to argue about
not including those two high-level
auditors which i think
we need badly once we have market-based
sourcing and single sales factor and
need to find people outside of the state
uh i don't represent women i don't know
what the house's position will be as it
comes to the
the auditor positions the the house
position was to include them
the senate position is to remove them so
the committee of conference would work
that out and i don't know where that
will end up
we will have to argue for that right
right and
and again i don't and i make no uh
suggestions on who's whose position will
be negotiated and where you'll end up
if we want to maintain our revenues
we've got to get those auditors
um representative spillsbury and then i
want to get back
to the base revenues for the rest of
them still he wipes to go
represent if my hands up i
again i'm finished okay
okay can you go back to the general
education trust fund estimates
now we want to go to meals and room
stocks
now that you get rid of the easy ones
we'll go to the hard ones
so so the the amount you see in 21 is
again reflective of what was collected
through
april um and then estimating what may
and june
would bring in and that's how you get to
the 320.4 million and 21
um and then in 22 the senate went to
342.8 and then in 23 359.9 and you can
see it's
very similar to what the the house had
um the the feeling
or the discussion was around there's
some pent-up
desire to get out um but that will
will will fade away pretty quickly as as
some of the
um stimulus money that individuals
received
um starts to diminish and um other
you know uh that pent-up demand
diminishes i guess for
lack of a better dis uh statement
so that's how they ended up at the you
know slightly ahead in 22 and then they
come down just slightly below
the house in 23 for the meals and rooms
estimates
mr chair can i start representing
uh so through may meals and rooms
revenue was 289.1
subtract 1.6 for the anomalies from last
year
so that we're down to 287.5
so now the question is again what what
do we think is going to come in
this month when we say this month it
really is
what was the activity last month
which is important because it's really
accelerating
we saw that in may's revenue which was
really
april's revenue was 27 million it almost
hit target
uh for the first time you know since the
pandemic so
so if we add the 20 let's if we take a
conservative view
and say well this month will be the same
as last month that's
that'll bring us up to 314.5
now which is which is 5.9 million below
uh the senate number i have a feeling it
may be above the 27
of may the main number uh so that's
where we gotta
discuss you know how much how much do we
think is going to come in may
uh last month 27 million came in
uh and that was really for april
so we're really saying well how much is
going to come in may that would be
revenue in june so um
and all i know is things are opening up
big time uh so
i i i i guess i don't have a problem
with the senate base number
uh but that base number would be 5.9
million more
than last month's remember the 27 that
came in
so i'll use that as a starting point for
the discussion
if you just take what's come in today
through the end of may 289.1 as
representative romney mentioned and the
plan
is 32.2 those two together is 321.3
which is within a few hundred thousand
dollars
of the senate now the 321.3 which is the
plan
last month from may it just about came
into the plan
this plan plan was 27.7
and what we received in june
in may so uh i think
we're probably going to hit very close
to the target
or might even exceed it so this 321.3
when you just add the plan to what's
already come in
and you compare that to what the senate
has come in i
sure they probably did the same they
where we would come in a little higher
than them
about 900 000. so that's another number
representations
yeah i just want to say that i'd go with
the senate number i don't think we're
going to do any better than that
and joan is undoubtedly going to be uh
a good month but uh probably consistent
with
historical months before this
pandemic hit us and uh so it seems in
the bald park and as i say i don't think
we're gonna do any better
does anybody feel who doesn't agree with
what
president james just said
for 21 representative
yeah i i think i agree with
representative ames
on we aren't completely recovered in our
area
and in when i i stayed in a bit
in a uh concord motel and
it still had a lot of empty rooms on
our restaurants people are still being
careful coming too
so i don't think we should go above plan
but i think plan is
uh fine a major um chair
um yeah i i'd go with the senate number
but you know the only the only
anchor that's dragging along the bottom
of
the c there is the uh we can't find
employees
uh i think that's going to be the real
real slowdown
until we get because some of these
hotels can't open to full capacity
because they don't have people
uh but um same thing with restaurants
but i'm i i think we just go with the
senate number
uh i think i think we're going to
definitely hit that
okay um the senate number was 320.4
and the if you look at the
era of growth and
meals and roams it said five to ten
percent
normally when there's no pandemic
we probably would get close to that five
percent
would come out to be what number
somebody got a calculator they can keep
it the senate took
seven percent for this year and then it
went down
to five percent and i calculated them
out
okay they took seven percent yeah and
okay that's why we there's 7 342.87
and that's really growing on a really
weak base if
pandemic never happened we would
our base would be much higher yeah
correct
yeah i'd go with seven percent it's
what's that uh representative um
our own march 18th figure uh for fy 22
was 341
extremely close to what the senate has
and i checked may may came in um
so do we want to take accept the senate
for the fy 22.
yes sure how about fy23
they have about five percent growth five
percent
and that's been the average over the
last number of years
the seven percent catches us up from a
bad base
and if you're not
an agreement to accept the senate
numbers for
fy for meals and rooms taxes just raise
your hand
otherwise we can proceed to the next
i don't see any hands raised tobacco
so so tobacco you see the sentence at
247.5
the house was at 247.8 in 22 they went
to 247.5
the house was at the reason for the
the flat projection in 22
um there was some feeling that
you're not going to see a lot of change
in some of the habits with related to
tobacco right now
that maybe in another year and a half to
two years you might see some some
programs start to help with
um you know decreasing the smoking that
people are engaged in but but
with people being home and and having
fallen back into some habits
there was a feeling that the tobacco
sales would continue to be fairly
consistent in 22 as it was in 21.
there's also some concern that um
um you know the cross-border sales will
continue
until the the federal government does
something with the menthol
or the the flavored tobacco
so and then and then again you see that
adjustment in 23 down to 240
so that was there the senate's position
of it slowing down
right that's a three percent slowdown
and typically
that's what we've been seeing year over
years about a three percent
does anybody have a problem with the
i don't see it the ind
[Music]
liquor yeah
uh well if you would like um we could go
through the
the business and and
revenues that dra collects while they're
on the call then i can go back after
and do the ones we didn't do in case
they need to get off i don't know but
just as a courtesy to them since they're
waiting with us
ind was a the senate was at 131.5
which was um 2.7 million above the house
position of 128.8
uh they went up to 138 and 22 which is a
one and a half increase one and a half
million dollar increase over the the
house position
and then they went up to 142.1 in 23
which was a
4.1 increase over the house position of
138.
i don't really have anything to
to suggest as to why how they got there
there was just some discussions that
they just felt there was going to be
um that level of revenue
i represent elmy thank you mr chairman
i calculated out again on the basis
of how much we get in june excluding
in the last five years
in terms of of june relative to the
entire year
and it comes out as 141.7 for the year
so the senate is
is um expecting a slowdown in june
by those numbers and i don't know
whether that's because they were using
the the april numbers when they did
their
analysis which uh did not include
so your 2021 number
for ind and on that basis it would be
141.7
on the average june was an average 14.1
percent
and didn't vary a whole lot around that
of the full year on
for for revenues so it's a question if
we're expecting
the more refunds to hit in june then
[Music]
124 to 132
so it's also that one is
also based on april only
i i'm sorry i i broke in there um but uh
what i i would say is that my general
view is that
interest and dividends we should should
expect it to be
relatively high because um it derives
significantly from the stock market
so i would i would go with the higher
number that uh representative army is
suggesting
it
i think we have to assume that some of
the people who have
moved here during the pandemic and paid
large amounts of cash for houses
and are working remotely are
newcomers to paying our dividends and
interest and dividends tax i think we
have a new
crop i think that's helpful
um what was your number
what was collected year to date
121.7 and add
the plan it's 139.1
and if you look at what
has been happening all year on
interest and dividend interest and
dividends running
22 on the average for 11 months
so what the plan was that would add
another
three point four it would come out
five to 142.5
so see what i did as i took what's been
received to date
and then the plan is 17.4 that's 139.1
and since the year to date for the last
11 months
it's been 22 an average of 22
10 of the plan is one point seven twenty
percent
is three point four you add that to the
one thirty nine point one
and you get one forty two point five and
that and i
there's no question that the uh senate's
low
um and you know just
bringing it up to plan what does that
bring is that up to 139.1 bringing it to
the
june plan i i i think we're not going to
go below june's plan
uh so yeah it's probably going to be
above
the 139.1 and definitely above
the senate's number because the center
okay with what you just said norm okay
so that i
i would go with susan's number 141.7
uh how does the rest
don't be afraid to say something guys
yes or no yes
okay sam yes then we're going to go with
the 141.7 for 2021
on interest and dividend the dra
estimates on 22 a four to six percent
range
and a two point two to four four percent
um so isn't it
did you bring those out to 23 20 22 and
i did check what the senate did
which i can't read i think that's a five
percent the first year
and i'm going down
percent the second year okay you're
right in the middle
on the second year no no up up three
percent the second year
right in the middle for the second year
three percent
what do we have for numbers 148 148.7
and 153.3 for the
three percent between 23.
thank you uh let me just check
you know the senate's way down i don't
and we know interest rates are going to
uh i do have i don't have a problem with
can someone repeat the 22 number 122
number is 141
7.
21. i mean that's 21. 140
8.8 222
and 153.3 what 23.
before we looks good to me yeah i mean
i'm okay with it
just just uh can we just ask dra why
we're so why their ranges are so much
lower than that
carol melissa
sure um just to give some information
may came in
how we anticipated the reason for the
decline in june is based on estimate
payments estimate payments have been
running about 5
below all year long so we
adjust made an adjustment to plan for
estimate payments
because it's not a return month it's an
the year to date
for 11 months we're running
22 above plan sure that's primarily
driven by returns and extensions and tax
notice payments
so the activity in 2020 um performed
better than what taxpayers anticipated
so when they filed their
their 2020 return in 2021 they paid more
than anticipated
and then it looks like they have
adjusted their estimate payments down
some compared to 2019.
so we we thought there would be a
decrease in june
as it's the second quarter estimate
payment to be more on trend
um with what we saw in march and april
for estimate payments compared to
2019. um
our trigger is what we come up with for
fy 2021.
and this 141.6
or 141.7 for 2021 looks like a good
number
now the senate had 131.5
because you said you said we added we
added plan
to the number so it must be that the dra
doesn't feel we're going to hit plan for
june is that what i'm hearing melissa
that's correct because okay because it's
an estimate month and we've been running
behind on estimate payments for ind
they've been reporting
less than anticipated
um estimates we
do not think that we'll hit plan for
june or ind
based on estimates not based on returns
and extensions
because those are not due in june so
how much lower would the
they're talking 10 million dollars so
we have um they can range between five
percent below plan
hold on one second we think excuse me
let me take it back we think they're
going to be around um
15 below plan for june
now plan is 17.4 million
10 would be 1.7
we think they're going to come in around
14.8 million
14.8 so that
14.8
[Music]
so that's 2.6 million dollars less
so if we adjust our base
2.6 then we would be down
i had 136.5 so did i
what did you how much did you adjust
the both 17.4
15 year-to-date
may plus 14.8
and may it up to me is 121.7
i think you need to take out the
anomalous from receivable
yes that's not in gas's number oh that's
yes okay
yeah that accounts for the 10 million
bucks
thank you melissa welcome
down it's down to 127.3 by my
numbers
um which is below senate
so our who we are we have
and we take out 14.8
and we take out the anomalies 15 the 15
is on the plan
and the plan was 17.4 and so that should
be
15 of 17.4 which would be
so the 127.8
minus the 9.2
right
with revenue then we got to add
then we got to say okay what's what's uh
what was what was june's plan again
june's plan was 17 4.
so 1 18.6
so 17.4 and we said and then
melissa what did you say what was that
15 how much below
plan percentage-wise
so that means uh yeah call of 14.8
33.4
so our just to give you a little bit
more information
um i'm trying to open numbers here but
our range for ind
is 124 to 132.
um so there's definitely room in there
if you think the 15
is is too low um
our high is 132 again
for ind with the anomalous
anomalous receivable removed
141 we've uh 0.7 we've got to take
and they're saying that that they think
june is going to come in at 14.8
so we then add that uh oh sorry not to
the 147. we'd add that to the we're
uh we're taking out 9.2
we're adding in 15 of
on 85 of plan
that dra said is 14.8
the um let me go over that
so we have and twenty one point
we removed nine point two million
dollars
because all right 121 yes i'm sorry yes
and then since we're going to reduce the
plan by
15 we're going to add another 14.8
and you add that as 127.3
and that ends up
right in the middle of what the dra
estimate was
basically the same as how much as our
match
a little bit less yeah a little less
127.3 versus 128.8
so what can we just stick with our march
estimates
yes
and then we can grow or grow that
life the five percent i'm going to grow
the 120
what's that i thought we had to agree to
the seven percent for the first year
no that was rooms and meals um
the senate was using the same median
middle
uh range which is five percent the first
year and then
four three percent the second year i'm
sorry
[Music]
135.3 yep i'm good
so what we have for
fy21 is 128.8
22 135.3
and 23 139.3 susan
what is that reasonable
yeah it sounds reasonable to me i think
the senate the senate's slightly higher
than we are
that's all right
we had a good discussion we corrected
the
we had people help steer us in the right
path
um who can we go with this
who who objects to going with these
numbers
then we will go with 128.8 for 20 21
135.3 for 22 and then
for 23 for inds
the next dra number is for
communications
wasn't it 127 3 for 21
it was but they kept the number we had
in march which is almost the same a
okay so that's what we'll go with for
that
for communications
communications uh so so the senate took
um the 39.1 for all three years it was
the adjustment that was provided by dra
and uh and so they had the april numbers
so
i'd say we go with the senate numbers
uh chris will provide us after this is
over he'll provide
okay so the next um revenue source is
the real estate transfer tax
yes the 2021 number for the senate was
204 million
which was an uh 10 million dollar
increase over the house weighs in means
of 194.
they dropped to 197 8 and 22 and then to
181.9 and 23.
there was some discussion that the um
the real estate sales will continue to
be strong at least in the first half of
the next year
um and then it'll start to slow down and
and
yeah they took off 3
and we took off a little bit more but
evenly divided pretty much
hey there's a base here can we start
with the base year
on fy21 go ahead representative
right may actual was 183.5
minus the 0.2 adjustment i think it was
0.2
yep uh yep 0.2
so so through may it's 183.3
now may we're at 15.5
uh red revenue
so that would bring us up to 198.8 if we
replicated may
but that's 5.2 million below the senate
space so
the question is again like the others
what do we think may is going to do so
uh and i'm not sure what may's plan was
um but on this one i don't know if plan
really makes any difference because it's
been
you know so much higher uh
but again if we i i'm starting to sense
a little slowing i
i don't know um
[Music]
in my town i knew anyway i mean it's so
anecdotal it doesn't
i shouldn't even say it but you know we
we have a magazine that comes out with
the sales for the month and it was it
was stacked about
six months ago was like a whole page
worth there were only three sales in my
town last year
last month um which got me a little
nervous
that you know so but anyway even if we
say may
and we say june is equivalent to may
in terms of red uh although we're in
is i forget is there a delay is there a
delay of a month in this on this
reporting of this one
as well yes yep right we are going into
the buying and selling season
so i would imagine that um june
could be higher so so i
i don't know we're at 183.3 if we stayed
with may's number
that would put us at 198.8 then it's
five point is that 204.
so do we feel that we feel that may is
going to be
uh 20 million point seven
questions when we compare ourselves to
okay represent
just anecdotally in charlestown for
weeks there's been exactly
one house on the market and one lot
uh yesterday a second house came on this
has been
a trend for a couple of months now that
inventory has really dropped
dramatically so prices are up but
yeah there we go interesting
conversation in hudson
which is you know like like you are norm
we're on the
so-called golden triangle of the
decade ago our sales are
down houses on the market are existing
houses
and we only have one new plan
development
only one and that's only going to be
five houses okay we want to
get fy2021
thank you on we i
am going by the newspaper index
at this point on we had been having
until mid-may i think we'd been having
on two to
we've been having four pages of closely
packed
house photographs for sale
in the emperor valley and we we are a
center of things
and we are going to be producing a lot
of housing later but
uh it's not going to be started until
next year on
and last weekend
on the day that the housing ads come
there were two pages of large pictures
of houses that is i think it was
something like 10 houses for the whole
upper valley area that were for sale
and they were for sale for huge amounts
okay the
revenue for fy21 ends
june 30th revenue collected in june
is primarily what was actually collected
in may so
essentially
we need to collect that information and
how much
is coming in and so far
sure so um for
[Music]
for our estimates we have 201.5
to 205.7 that is with
june coming in on the low end
20 above plan and on the high
end 35 percent above plan
for the month is 15 million for june
20 above plan would be it add another
three percent
uh another three million
so do we want to uh split it
let's say the difference is four 1.5
sounds right on
201.5
so we the suggestion is 201.5 and
represent only did you have another
suggestion oh
sorry no i just said i wouldn't go above
that one but
okay no it's okay then uh
we all okay with 201.5 i don't see any
hands raised
that's probably a good number so we
that's a good number for
2021.
now we go to 20 22.
and the dra estimates
it'll drop seven
their estimate range from uh minus seven
percent drop to minus two percent drop
for
and a a two percent drop
essentially it would be 1
97.5 a
7 drop
somebody wrote a calculator because it
183.6 or 0.64 so i'll call it six or
seven
okay
do we want to go and the difference is
before take the 2021 and reduce it by
four and a half percent yeah that's the
midpoint
yeah i'm okay with the midpoint
reduction okay
the guy with a calculator
oh what was it four and a half percent
yep
192.2 all right allen you're faster
okay and then to 23
23 the estimators dropped
minus 10 minus 8. so
mr chairman i think we really you have
to anticipate something like this
the price of new housing is going
through the roof it's going to take a
while before they figure out how to
if we ever do figure out how to make
housing slightly more affordable again
to anybody
and i don't know if all of the big
projects that are being planned
so they're needed by uh businesses
and in our town are going to to
be built given how much the cost of
construction is going up okay
what we have is we have for fy 2021
201.5 million dollars
fy22 we dropped by four and a half
percent to 192.2
fy23 we dropped by 9 to 174.9
seems right those are still those are
above what our original estimates were
so they're they're below the senate but
the housing market did hold up for a
while but it really seems to be hitting
them i
don't see anybody chafing at the bit to
disagree with us
so we're going to go with that the next
[Music]
chris
i guess i was muted yeah utility
property tax again it's a number that
dra provided
it's the 40.6 um for all three years
again there's not a lot of activity or a
lot of change with that
when they came into the house it was
42.3 for all three years
so they had the benefit of an additional
completed month
so and saw that it was trending downward
does anybody have a problem we go over
the
latest dra estimates of one
the statewide property tax that's
that's set in law yep set to 363.1
um so we can't change that
medicaid recovers
that is there's no change from the house
um estimates that were provided by the
agency so they're still at 3.3 and 2.7
2.5 um
so dras everything that they would in on
discussed so what's left is just the
what i would call the other agency
revenues and i can
go through those relatively quickly if
you would like
that i would so
we just did medicaid recoveries um i'll
take you up to tobacco settlement
the 47.8 million is what actually came
in the door
for 21 in april
um there was no change to the estimates
in 22 or
23. the department of justice still goes
with the thirty point
thirty eight point two and the thirty
six point three million
in twenty two and twenty three respects
we'll take the senate numbers for the
uh lottery revenue the agency came into
senate
and bumped their 21
estimate up to 128
from what they had been estimating to be
around 120
and then in 22 and 23 they kept their
estimates the same at 125 and 127.5
i'll note here that the house had an
estimate of 130.6 and that was based on
what had come in the door
at that point and trending it out with
plan going forward
and you're probably going to be really
so the only difference is in the 21
number we're done yep
so so again senate senate ways and means
took the agency's estimate of 128
which came up from 120 that they had
provided to the house ways and means
house ways and means
um trending the the revenue out for the
rest of the year
no i think we keep on 130.6
expresses right okay we'll keep our
numbers
any problems with that good the next one
um the next one is the other revenue
so the agency came down uh came down on
their estimates in
um all three years 22
21 22 and 23 and the
um senate ways and means accepted those
adjustments
did they give any reason why uh just the
year to date the trending in some of the
transfers from the agencies that that
the revenue source has come from
have been down but they didn't have one
specific reason
as to why it was trending downward so we
go with the agency's numbers
the beer tax there was no difference
from where the house was with the
estimates the
still 13.2 for all three years the same
way with the securities
exactly there was no change in the um
agency's estimates the same as what they
provided the house
they're called fines and keys there's uh
a slight adjustment um in the
22 and in 23 but
the 21 number remained at the 12.3
million
and basically uh donna raymond who
who provides the court information
just relooked at the numbers and
felt that some things were starting to
trend in a positive direction where she
thought
it was going to be a little slower in
that recovery as the courts opened up
and some of the processing has occurred
so she anticipated a slight bump up
in 22 and then being more normal i guess
in 23 with their revenue stream
at 13 million so um
how's the house members feel
on the latest
senate numbers based upon
historically i'd go along with the court
system they have
a history in which the senate has always
bumped them up to challenge them and
then
they'd come in anyway lower than what
the senate had bumped them to
so if this if justice is actually
volunteering these
uh the court system then i think we
anybody disagree with that i don't see
anybody disagreeing with that
so the next one is is insurance
so insurance came in at 135 in fiscal
year 21
and then 130 and 22 and 135 and 23 with
the senate weighs in means compared to
the
house position of 130 um 128 and 134
and and again they saw better revenue
streams in 21 and and
as they projected outward that's caused
the slight uptick in the out years
uh mr chair and chris um do i look at
revenue focus
as a through the end of may we're
already at 1 38
with one month left yep
what i don't know is if there's going to
be any adjustments before the end of the
year
so it may it may trend to be closer to
that number but i just don't know if
there's an adjustment coming
and sure does a good job in their
estimates
so we're saying let's just accept the
latest insurance
yeah i'm not sure how the refunds work
in the insurance so
all right i'm okay
um so the next one is liquor that's the
last one on this page
um even and then in 22 liquor came in at
141.6
and in 23 at 141.2
you'll see the senate has a number of
137.6
and a number of 137.2 and 22 and 23
respectively
so as you might remember in fiscal year
there was an 8.2 million dollars
transferred from the liquor fund
to the granite advantage fund or the
medicaid expansion fund
back in 2019 there was a piece put in
law that said if that fund
was projected to have a shortfall that
the commissioner
of hhs could request a transfer from the
liquor fund
to make up for that shortfall since that
transfer
the department of health and human
services has acknowledged that they
expect there'll be another transfer need
in 22 but they don't know how much
they also have they're in the process of
renegotiating some of the
contracts with the providers and they
believe that's going to save some money
so they're still unable to provide
how much because those those are ongoing
negotiations so the senate
felt at least conservatively knowing
that the department has indicated they
anticipate some sort of a transfer in 22
and 23
to just budget four million dollars less
in the liquor fund
and assume that that's the amount that
represented thomas southwood
uh thank you mr chair just checking i
drive by the new uh liquor store in
epsom
uh and i just wondered did they have a
formula for adding that in so now it'll
be open the whole month of june
and then of course it'll be open for a
whole year starting in july
i assume they figure that in but i was
just curious
yeah the um so they they have uh
revenue projections for each of their
stores um
and then when they do a renovation or a
new store
um they have some sort of an adjustment
related to that so there'll be some
adjustment downward during the
renovations and then they'll have an
adjustment going up
um after the store opens um
the typically um the committee hasn't
asked
for that information from them but i
think they could provide it if you
wanted to see it
no that's okay i just want to make
assume they have a formula so that's
taken care of
thank you you're welcome
so that go ahead
representative thank you so if they took
four million off of each year
uh then still that's considerably higher
still than
what we had i think yes
so um the liquor commission
increased their revenue estimates by a
fair amount
yes yep and liquor has been doing
a good job with their estimates
um then
does anybody have any questions on any
of these that we've
gone over because if not and this will
be
the house ways and means position when
we go into
so rip some major what i'll do is i'll
i'll basically take this sheet
i'll put in your estimates from today
with today's date
yes um down here
we'll keep i'm going to take out the uh
dra auditors because that's not in there
at the moment
so so that there's no place for that to
occur
right we're going to have to fight for
that dra
and then we'll add in the the 25 4 and
the 44 related to payroll protection
um
excuse me the d-a-r-r-d-r-a auditors i
would leave it to 3 million because that
was the house position
yes yeah okay that i'm sorry and then i
would leave the 20
single sales factor delay 20 million
here yes because that was the house
position
and i would include the ppp numbers but
i would not move over the
uh meals and rooms fund or the
additional negotiating
right right so that takes care of your
general fund education trust fund um you
do have your highway fund and your
fishing game fund i just want to go
through that real really quickly with
you
there's a slight uptick in your highway
funds
so there's and it's all in 21 mostly but
um so the gas road uh road toll
is up by 1.7 million dollars over the
house position again um steve lavoy from
the department of safety you know as
they saw what was happening through
april
um the numbers were a little bit better
than they had anticipated when they came
in
in the middle of march to discuss it
with you for your committee
still 16 million under plan yes yeah
it's
slightly better it's not um at plan
again and then the same with the motor
vehicle registrations
they saw an uptick in 21 um you know
through
april that suggested that would be
you know a little bit higher by the end
so you'd see a 2.5 million dollar
difference from the
the house position um the the
miscellaneous revenue doesn't change
that's related to stuff that happens
with transportation
but so so that's um you know again it's
a slight uptick but it's not
um you know anything crazy but i wanted
and then the fishing game fish and game
is even less drastically changed the
only change is in their other revenue in
21 it's a hundred thousand dollars
higher
again that was based on what they had
received to date through
april um so and they felt that the 3.7
million was more reflective of what how
fiscal year 21 would end with their
other revenue any questions
on the highway fund estimates and the
fish and game estimates
only will we agree with the senate
estimates
on i might i tried to figure out the
21 uh highway fund and
came in with within 200 000
of them and and just to
reiterate that the senate took exactly
what the agency provided to them
with the um highway fund so we'll take
the
senate numbers for the highway fund
and as you might recall in the email
that i sent i had a link in there
if you click on that link it should take
you to all the various agency documents
that were provided to the senate so if
you did have an interest in seeing
um the narrative that the agency might
have provided it would be found there
we'll take the center numbers for the
any problems if not
then that will be our position
any questions or comments from the
committee i'd like to make a comment
yes and the comment is
uh that you you as chair have really
done a superb
job in shepherding us through this
task and i thank you for that and also
chris shea
and dra backing us up and guiding us
uh you know we all know that we're doing
the best we can
we're dealing with a lack of data and
unpredictability in the future but uh
we're doing
the best we can i'm thankful for that
well thank you representatives um
anybody else comments questions if not
then we uh just as soon as
entered in into you know updated
his tables i'll get them out
to the full committee as a matter of
fact chris if you're sending the full
committee
yeah position committee conference
and because we have threatened through
this you do not need
to come together tomorrow
so represent major what i'll do is i'll
put together the document i'll send it
to you in an excel in a pdf as i've done
in the past
and if anybody finds any errors or has a
question
or anything that's not what you thought
was agreed to please let me know so that
we can get it fixed and resent back out
yes so would you like a motion
to adopt this as the position
just to have a one vote
today uh you make that a motion
yes i do i recommend that the
uh i move that we adopt the figures as
discussed
so that they are the position of ways
house ways and means
at the committee on conference uh three
seconds
i will and that's representing the early
representative bernstein uh
any further comments saying no further
comments represent bernstein i'm going
to take the vote
sure on the motion let's begin the roll
yes
mary griffin representative ulrich
yes representative doucette
it's fred no longer on the call
uh representative burst team votes yes
i didn't hear anything say that one more
yes daddy representative genigean
yes representative nunes
yes don't see representative baxter here
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes representative
army
yes representative ames yes
let's move on to rep the honorable
representative thomas c
schamberg representative thomas c
schamberg votes ea
thank you sir representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo yes
representative lofman is not here
representative gorg
is not here representative hacken
phillips
representative murphy yes
and chairman major yes now
i think he had to leave by noon
for a meeting mr chair there were 18
members
casting votes all 18 voted yes
thank you very much i
you know we had a great discussion uh
there's nobody perfect nobody knows all
the answers
but as we discuss these things we find
out more and more about it
i think we did an excellent job thank
you very much
and we won't be meeting tomorrow and jen
would you um how do you handle that
just put a note so if somebody does try
to come in
i can let karen know and then she'll
officially cancel the meeting
thank you you'll be all set all right
and then uh we'll wait and see what
happens with the committee at
conferences
and we'll we'll be seeing you on
thursday yes
yes mr chairman i want to thank you for
that
as well as this whole year
remind people that the next term
budget is going to be even harder for us
to figure out
i think so we need to all look
at uh over the term at what's going on
with our stimuli and what they're doing
to us
thanks cape reading
the wall street journal financial times
economists and listening to
all your economies and we commit
and your
local committees businesses because we
need all that information
for getting ready for the next budget
all right thank you jennifer has his
hand up
norm nice to see you uh
representative spillsbury yeah quick
curiosity
in the same way that we just took a
motion do we put this before the house
on thursday
to revise the officially adopted uh was
that not done
no this is our position when we go to
the committee conference
it's yep it's been a great year guys
even though we had to operate on
dependent
conditions all right then uh
thank you thank you
impossible